[Music]
welcome alright i'll or podcast lords of
gaming down that the Lords in the realm
one of the most highly anticipated games
off streets a wink at the camera they
get to see that Streets of Rage for we
got the entire Lords with us we got Lord
King David Lord hide we got shaft aka
G and of course Lawson Aldo TV we are
debuting the new mold four-player local
co-op Streets of Rage for y'all or we
got the classic and whoo-hoo - Adam what
a that's my one all Kings got a nice
right black with the yellow shirt for
once yeah you're the Lords have really
waited for this get weary streets know
that Lord gene who are you taking sir oh
oh yeah okay nice it looks like Max from
Part 2 but we cybernetic arms with Jack
cybernetics Laurence now no who are you
take I will take classic blaze classic
blaze it out and of course Lord hide we
keep it old-school with classic axle
correct okay wait oh you got Floyd okay
okay okay
so Lord gene you have axle you have
classic axle
Adam okay okay so who the hell has Axl
okay cool cool I thought you had Adam
survived my bad I'll bet you're Axl so
he gettin it on Oh your man with Floyd
Floyd Mayweather four player co-op
actually looking really cool basically
giving you guys a setup at a game play
first then we'll meet actually with
developer after it is to give you that
footage but what to give you a feel of
the latest mode the latest trailer the
latest actual character which is again
Floyd knew too that this series and it's
really cool to see Adam back y'all
yellow shirt with the straight with the
shades classic vintage character from
part one one of the favorites we've been
missing him for but oh I see the kick
action I see that kick action right
there Oh special moves last year yeah I
like the combo potential now the
question is let's see if y'all could do
the combos together number you could
grab your guy can you do that lets see
some combos together
yeah I don't look like maybe this mold
they're not allowing that feature so
that no one's hitting each other this is
somewhat chaotic
and associated animations look really
really cool y'all
diggin it somebody bus to telephone box
there you go Laura P do get chicken
fight for the chicken look at a person
approach about spamming to get the
chicken though
yo dad new Floyd character look beast
yeah he's bees it's good
yo that grapa waveshape move yo he's
better than max Loki max the trouble
with Florida round
yeah they set up for a combo like a
combo slaughter
[Music]
Oh let's go Axl okay yeah
so cool to see them break this poor
player mold
obviously to to console what would be
awesome is if we can get this also
online because we believe there's a two
player online co-op oh oh we see the
little home I like the animations for
the UM for Adam on that kick super there
like a little dragon her son came out
you got the whole squad
your white shock is your man up like
this please leave Donovan alone leave
down over the law
nice I love that kick Adams doing oh
you'll hide that kick with the with the
join the commodities that's fire
yeah that kick right there I like that
one that's the kick I like
yeah whatever that the move is five
house blaze feeling stop eating I want
to see some special balls from gotta see
what we could do
everybody doing yesterday we would his
oh there you go what's OH the backflip
is fired
yeah backflip again but the other kick
vintage axle oh oh you're dangerous
stolen cars out now from what I
understand in the original Streets of
Rage but we spoke to Cyril last time
that was part of the initial design to
have those type of armed cars coming to
the game but what ended up happening was
due to graphical limitations and stuff
on the cutting room floor they couldn't
get it in but it's good to see them
working with Sega bringing out a lot of
classic features that back in the day
they weren't able to implement in time
and for this reimagining of the series
so this is really cool loving the four
player co-op action here really cool as
you can tell the team is enjoying it
Oh
why I refer them up King why y'all
rougher them up the fight but it's in no
actual or why axel always buy the
chicken is that you chef is that you
always buy the chicken are you to do Oh
Cobo nobody know what to smoke with Cobo
yeah I want to smoke with cold water
yo what's that charge you'll be doing
like a little mini boss right
[Laughter]
why are you guys here like that Kolb oh
yeah so with the head action
[Laughter]
I'm over idea it's crazy
why is he throwing spinning pipes Tom
hit the trees we go to the pit all we
want to train you all your means you get
your meds oh oh oh that's his hole
that's what you know he comfortable here
that's his hurricane the real
comfortable son what's his name die lon
die lon yo die line is real comfortable
so he got people out here you got fired
I line I like that character bottle so
whoever did that character model for the
dialogue oh no they got the jiggers to
do that you think nobody do then you
stick just run like that they have no
animated he's a speed walk into you with
the knife I remember those
I gotta find out his name shipmaster why
is it was the old dial on his back you
know he's so smooth with he see don't
even pull his ears out we fight you
comfortable oh yeah busted Donovan up
now busted Donovan up out there that's
crazy which I doing it down of him
love the are animations they watch axel
actually get all the fool who's accident
that's King always by the chicken always
by the chicken
train train it all that's how we go this
let's go where the Cobras bow
Oh cow SIA
I think that self to God you go yeah I
like the Train
Oh boss value for her that's that's a
now though for her solo with blaze it's
for y'all I expect a very that's nice
it's for y'all we're hoping to worry
about that
this is cool crazy [ __ ]
oh okay please okay sound oh that's the
stream team Lee right there that's the
stream team lead
and with the phone my dad died she
charge it up Georgia Devo miss diva oh I
told you got people out here dylon
that's a that's a mess a lieutenant fire
oh that's Kevin yo it's Kevin Killa keV
oh no this is five the fact that they
added four player co-op Streets of Rage
broad with I almost need this online now
oh boy disrespectful they just grabbed
so did Freud just choke we don't have to
speak the word take Freud HR out here we
disrespectful with them cybernetic arms
I can't front and I'm a max fanboy so it
hurt me that Max's it back but fried is
making me not miss max I go front boys
the big boy yeah boy edit let's see I'm
saying he don't skip the gym
congratulations
we did it stage one clear the Lords of
the realm Streets of Rage for four
player co-op we did it your first debut
here Lords of gaming down that a little
podcast you saw it here first
shoot arranged for let's ask real quick
Lords little King how we feeling Lord
Jeep how we opt we say go back in the
building baby and just for you know
Lord's sake it does with Nintendo I'm
just kidding it's all platform I'll or
podcast Lord gave me down there
[Music]